The first two are equal to negative 1, the 3rd one is equal to positive 1, and
the last one is something else. We know these first two are equal to negative 1
since each rational expression contains opposite polynomials. The x terms are
opposite in sign here, and the y terms are also opposite in sign. So we know
that this fraction can simplify to negative 1. The same is true for this
fraction. The b squared terms are opposite in sign, the 5b terms are opposite in
sign and the constant of 1 is also opposite in sign. I didn't show the factoring
here, but we know that it will equal negative 1 if we remove a factor of
negative 1 from the denominator and cancel our trinomial. In our third example,
the y terms have the same sign, and the x terms have the same sign. So really,
this fraction is the same expression. In this third rational expression, the y
terms have the same sign, as do the x terms. If we switch the order of addition
in the numerator, we'll have x minus y divided by the quantity x minus y. We
know these expressions are exactly the same, so we really have 1 divided by 1,
or just positive 1. For this last expression, we know it needs to equal
something else. We can't just square each term and call it a day. We know that
this is really x plus 2 times x plus 2. When we square a binomial, we get a
perfect square trinomial. Looking at this numerator and denominator, we know
that our fraction doesn't equal positive 1 or negative 1.